[Music]
you know seen very well the room full of
kids we're just going back to the basics
okay
I definitely feel really bad putting jr.
in a class with children but
unfortunately that's where she is the
pageant is in three months and let's
just say I feel like I'm starting at the
beginning okay
we need to get started I'm so sorry late
this is Helen she'll be your instructor
this Helen lady is probably the scariest
lady I've ever seen she'd need some hair
etiquette June you are in great hands
oh my god girl you okay we're not
getting off to a good start
all right I will just go I'll see you in
a little bit Newt sign me up for a kitty
Erica class I mean what the so today
we're gonna learn some things about
dining etiquette and we're gonna talk
about how we are to eat soup I'm going
to eat the ball up and just fluff it out
the bowl no no no we don't want to do
that we want to miss Poona out okay and
then for this soup because it's more of
a hearty vegetable we will bring it
forward okay like curtsey and stuff
honey I already know how to eat these
drawers me or loosen up and have some
fun let me see how you're holding your
spoon no no no no no take your elbows
off the table
who cares about a spoon now a four it's
actually really good for a head
scratcher
I wish you would please put the fork
down salads are mixed right crunch it no
no you don't
is that funny see she thinks it's funny
I like her she do not leave the garnish
part no story and you're caught I mean I
wanna come on now are you gonna do this
seriously I've got a hold on with all
your snooty [ __ ] in the pageant don't
worry your pretty little head off just
let your coach worry about that
mama give me a toothpick you know I want
yours you use that what's reusable I
think that this etiquette class is for
good manners
you obviously don't have any Oh all
garters cause the mache tada
[Music]